If it is taking a while for the next lead to come in four plus days and business owners already given out the first estimate, are you doing soft touches in between or are you only calling them when you have a lead?
Definitely do soft touches, bro.
So here's the thing, guys, we're coming in for all of us that are in this group.
Those are you that were my freaking OGs that joined the for the very first batch of people.
You guys were the first cohort, by the way, shout out to all you guys when this was just a freaking thought in my head and you guys gave me money and you're like, I think this guy is going to pull through, man.
I think I shout out to you guys.
OK, I know I gave you guys a discount, but I can't thank you guys enough for trusting me.
And anyway, I always say that because I feel indebted to you guys.
Thank you. OK, but for those of you that are the OGs that joined back last year, we did this.
We launched this thing in the middle of the winter, in the middle of the quote unquote worst month of the year.
OK, and guys, trust me.
And when I say quote unquote, it's because I think every month is bad in some way and good in some way.
OK, it's bad because it's harder to get leads.
But guess what? The business owners are hungry.
The summer is bad because the business owners are full.
Their stomachs are full, but it's it's easier and it's good because the leads are cheap because, you know, people need the service stuff.
So I believe I say it's bad because everyone looks at it like that's the slow time.
We launched this thing in December and we had people getting deals left and right and all the rest.
So first and foremost, if you see a slowdown, it's part of the game.
And as we start to see these slowdowns, there's weather, there's recession,
there's this whole thing with the opting out of the search networks, et cetera.
Right. We just have to be strategic.
Go back to our the setup, go back to overcoming, sorry, not overcoming, eliminating objection.
If you are seeing that, just bring it up.
So when you get on and you hook the business owner, say, hey, Mr.
Business Owner, hey, Mrs. Business Owner, I'm going to get you a couple of leads.
I don't know if it's going to be tomorrow, if it's going to be in three days.
It might take a couple of weeks. I want to get you some good ones.
OK, so I'll I'll be in touch, but let me get you a couple of good ones and then let's talk.
And then my rule of thumb is I usually get them if they close the first lead,
boom, I'm pitching it or I get them, you know, three to five leads or I just feel that it's right.
So, Drew, all I would say, yeah, for sure, do the soft touches.
You can maybe let them know, hey, you know, whatever.
We've got some some funky calls coming in.
It's pretty normal this time of year.
If it's not a big deal to you, it's not a big deal to them.
We've I've closed plenty of deals in October or November now.
This is a great month still.
And guys, we launched this thing in December and people were closing deals left and right.
So it's it's something we're just got to realize we're going to
we're going to be sending these people less leads.
If you've been sending people seven leads, we might only be sending them three leads.
What that means that we got to get every lead we need to squeeze it.
OK, we can't just waste a lead at this point. Good question.
Guy says he likes my zoom in the king of digital real estate.
You know it, bro. OK, soft touches are some of the things I just said.
Just just touching in, man, just be a human like, hey, how'd that go?
Did you did you get that? Did you pitch him?
Cool. Did you need me to follow up?
Are you going to follow up? Awesome.
Well, let me just tell you what we got going on over here.
Like, just be a human.
The more soft touches you have.
I like to have a lot of soft touches until we close the deal.
I still like to have a lot of soft touches until we resign the contract.
And then after that initial contract is when you can kind of pull back
and just kind of self-regulate in my experience.